and i went
like that on his car door like that and
the the picture looks like i'm whacking
this cab like in a mad crazy drunk state
it wasn't the case at all and the
headline was atack attacks a taxi
the first image in my camera roll
really let's have a look
i've got 33 000 images on my phone
mostly nudes
no they're all like mostly selfies
oh god that's going to take me a while
[Music]
this looks really touchy now
halfway there
i'm so close
right here we go
um
so this
i was leaving keith lemon's birthday
party
um
and it was a fancy dress and i went as
wayne from wayne's world and i was
absolutely hammerooned
the last one
is
a picture of my little puppy
my baby girl
my first kiss
god my first kiss um i was 10 it was in
a park and it was with a boy called
adrian
and then i realised i really like i
really enjoyed it it was really fun so
then i went and snogged his best mate
darren a few minutes later
my last kiss lost a chance
the first fake news story written about
me
ah right this actually this is quite
funny um i was i was coming out of a
party and there was a pep in sitting in
the bush i didn't know he was there and
a taxi was kind of backing out uh in the
road i was sort of waiting for my lift
and the taxi nearly ran my foot over he
was like backing up and i went
like that on his car door like that and
the the picture looks like i'm whacking
this cab like in a mad crazy drunk state
it wasn't the case at all and the
headline was attack attacks a taxi
got to give it to them that is brilliant
um the last fake news story written
about me
worryingly a lot of it's true i go how
the hell did you know that
the first time i realized i was famous
what i thought this is what i thought
was happening a guy came over to me i'd
been on the in between us for a little
bit and he went his shoe isn't it and i
was about to go yeah i was like
yeah it is yeah he was like i knew it i
was like yeah do you wanna pick and you
went yeah do you know what i loved you
and girls are loud
i thought it was kimberly walsh
the last time i realised i was famous
i'm sitting here now like you don't come
to lab bible if you're not famous
the first time i got really drunk
um i was at paul mccartney concert um
and i'm related to paul mccartney and we
went to a paul mccartney gig i was 13
and he'd he'd given us a vip room um and
it was like a family room and all the
family were kind of preoccupied you know
there was like a massive buffet loads of
champagne i was quietly necking all the
champagnes without anyone knowing and i
was
so very ill
my first ever hangover oh
the last time i got really drunk last
night next
the first note in my phone
[Music]
oh my god right
it's basically a breakup message that i
was
sort of planning out
and i didn't know how to say it
uh
worryingly i've got quite a few of those
in here azam's
different names
my dearest different it's terrible the
last note in my phone oh last note in my
phone
dishwasher tablets
times have changed
oh my god
it tastes like
it tastes a little bit like sweaty
bollocks
so sorry
and anyone that goes
i don't know what sort of bollocks
you've had no come on like if you say it
doesn't taste like that you're lying
because it does